in diesem eindrücklichen dokument dafür
den berichten menschen von ihren
erfahrungen mit dem stimmen hören
das sind erfahrungen die angst machen
das sind aber auch erfahrungen die
beglücken
wir sind hier in einem rahmen der
universitären psychiatrischen dienste in
bern ein kompetenzzentrum für
psychiatrie und psychotherapie andreas
wabl wie äußert sich beim dieses
phänomen des stimmen hören es bei ihnen
jetzt verschiedene phasen kommen wo
ihnen gehört hat oder eigentlich viel
mehr so allein einen inneren sehr hoch
so zu sagen was haben sie gehört wen
haben sie gehört vor allem eigentlich
menschen die ich kenne oder menschen
auch der geschickt mit denen ich von dir
ins gelesen hatte im zweikampf jetzt was
für eine schöne gehört von einer
bekannten persönlichkeit der
kirchengeschichte und das war noch ganz
spannend weil der wagen muttersprache
nicht deutsch und jemanden der sprache
spricht er mit ihr und die frage war für
mich völlig fremd
es war wie so ein herz zu herz
kommunikation die wirklich jenseits
irgendwelcher sprachigen stattgefunden
hat das erinnerte er gerade an pfingsten
oder menschen in sprachen gesprochen
haben die sie gar nicht verstehen die
anderen die nicht verstehen konnten und
doch verstanden haben in der bibel gibt
es viele tolle geschichte ich denk an
die taufe von jesus von nazareth geht
sogar der himmel auf es öffnet sich der
himmel eine stimme aus dem menü sagt
dies ist mein geliebter sohn haben wir
so diesen bezug des in den fast
täglichen bezug dazu verloren bleiben
oft zu sehr am phänomen hänge so also
jemand hat eine stimme die es
möglicherweise noch irgendwie negativ
oder filme machen wir ein symptom
draußen diagnose und medikation und
vergessen sie zu fragen was sagt denn
diese stimme also auch pfingsten zum
beispiel vielleicht ist das größte
wunder dass die leute die alle
hört haben in ihrer sprache gar nicht
ausgesprochen
aber da ist eigentlich auch die größere
frage ist ja was haben sie denn
eigentlich geprägt wie hat das
innenlebens kontext gepackt der leute
ihm zugehört haben hat sich das
ausgewirkt das ist wir haben nicht so
viele leute die irgendwie sich an
deeplinks geschichte erinnern was würden
sie sowie hat sich ausgewirkt dass 500
oder tausende sind getaucht worden da
sie manchmal denkt man wenn man das
heute psychiatrisch begleitet hätte
zugesagte phänomen diagnose medikation
wer weiß ob wir heute ein küchentuch
wenn ich die ersten 500 dagegen werden
spannende frage wo ist denn die grenze
lässt sich das fahren zwischen eben eine
eingebung vielleicht sogar einer
wirklichen eingebung und einer
psychischen krise
wir haben der mensch der in der schweiz
leute ausbildet für die stimmen höher
arbeit er sagt immer es gibt keine
stimmen die nicht eigentlich auch eine
botschaft haben
insofern würde sehr denken das ganze
team kontinuum und die den wirklichen
immer fan davon zu unterscheiden ist es
nicht viel qualität
oder es ist sicherlich relevant und
sozusagen das hat lange gedauert aber
heute möglich werden mit stolz ich bin
wirklich beides ein spiritueller mensch
und genauso sich diagnostik
sie haben sich auf ausbilden lassen zur
pr beraterin sie beraten oder begleiten
betroffene menschen bestimmen werden
dass man sie komplett also konkret das
so dass es eine ausbildung gibt für
leute die selber kriegen und genesungs
erfahrung haben um dann auf der
grundlage andere zu begleiten
ich mache das im moment konkret in
internaten in der tat klinik hat der
heiße gespräche mit leuten begleitet
gruppen und was bringen
andrea zur herzlichen dank für diesen
einblick in die welt des stimmen hören
ja hier sehen sie in einer woche einen
weiteren film am nächsten sonntag
nämlich
ja du kurier sieht afrikanerin aus
gambia und sie setzt sich mit ganzem
einsatz gegen die mädchenbeschneidung 1
sie selbst beschnitten worden als sieht
eine woche auf ein film der berührt
empfehlen der aufregung
[Musik]